bonjour bienvenue sur l'a7 4 tv donc ce
matin nous avons procédé à la nouvelle
élection de la mandature du conseil
général des jeunes donc bonjour à tous
donc il y a le nouveau bureau qui est
présent ainsi que guillaume qui fait
partie de la précédente mandature donc
donc je vous présente il ya t shirt sa
mairie qui est le nouveau président du
conseil général des jeunes il y a
mélissa abrantès la deuxième vice
président du conseil général des jeunes
et vis dot nicolas qui est le 3e vice
poésie le deuxième vice-président pardon
sa mairie je souhaitais savoir qu'est ce
qui t'a poussé à être candidat à la
présidence du conseil général des jeunes
mais ce qui m'a poussé à être candidat
au conseil général des jeunes
c'est que depuis l'entrée en sixième
j'ai assumé mes missions dignement avec
compétence et sérieuse au sein des
différents conseils par exemple le
conseil d'administration le conseil
d'hygiène concédé 10 city et conseils de
classe et puis c'est parce c'est aussi
peut-être que je me projette aussi dans
l'avenir peut-être de faire de la
politique c'est très bien et toi
mélissa donc qu'est ce qui t'a poussé à
être candidate
je me suis présentée pour être candidat
parce que l'année dernière quand j'étais
suppléante du conseil général
deux collèges j'ai participé aux projets
et aux sorties et je trouvais que
c'était que c'était très intéressant
donc ben j'ai proposé je me suis
présenté pour proposer mes projets merci
et toi nicolas puisque vous avez été élu
donc maintenant comment vous sentez donc
qu'est ce qui t'a poussé également être
candidat donc je suis délégué depuis la
sixième donc j'ai toujours aimé
représenter mes camarades de classe et
donc l'année dernière j'étais aussi
suppléant que deux au collège saint
michel avec mon petit chou fleur birman
thein cortese et samassa va motiver
frange est du l'ambiance au conseil
général des jeunes j'ai tout de suite eu
envie de faire partie du bureau
voilà merci à toi donc maintenant je
vais poser la question à guillaume poids
qui est de la précédente mandature
donc je voulais savoir par rapport ce
qui s'est passé ce matin donc calé
qu'est ce que tu pourrais me dire de ta
passation de ton titre à la nouvelle
mandature comment tu as vécu cette
matinée c'est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'émotions voilà donc moi j'aimerais
avoir ton ressenti
alors tout d'abord lors de cette
passation j'ai eu deux sentiments de
sentiment vraiment
important tout d'abord j'ai été un peu
triste puisque je quitte un poste qui
vraiment me tient à coeur puisque
l'année que j'ai passée avec le conseil
général des jeunes a été une année très
fructueuse avec beaucoup de projets mise
en oeuvre comme des actions avec lohan
est fou le concours de slam de danse
urbaine
mais le cjc surtout aussi une famille
avec des amis inoubliable avec avec
lesquels on a un lien extrêmement liés
c'était aussi nick ans enrichissante et
incroyables notamment avec le
développement de l'aisance devant un
public et donc aussi de la confiance en
soi mais je suis aussi très rassuré est
content puisque voir une équipe aussi
motivé qu'on a aujourd'hui
ça apporte aussi une bouffée d'oxygène
au conseil général des jeunes et donc un
certain renouveau donc pour conclure je
dirais que cette passation m'a beaucoup
aidé sur le plan professionnel et
personnel puisque le conseil général m'a
apporté beaucoup et j'espère qu'il nous
apportera beaucoup aussi
merci guillaume donc c'est vrai que lors
de cette instance
nous sommes quand même sollicité par
beaucoup de partenaires pour participer
à des actions
donc là on va démarrer dès le 14
novembre avec la bpdj pour les
attractions journée tous ensemble contre
les drogues
nous allons également participé pour au
mois de novembre toujours pour les
actions sur vivre en santé vivent en
bonne santé en partenariat avec les reps
et bien sûr également le conseil général
des jeunes
donc va et participer pour à
l'exposition graines de volcans qui
organisé par la direction de la
communication
donc nous sommes que l'instance du
conseil général des jeunes
et quand même sollicité par beaucoup de
partenaires et bien sûr tout au long de
l'année il y aura d'autres actions qui
viendront se greffer à cette à cette
instance est en tout cas j'espère que
nous allons travailler toujours dans la
même
ligne et c'est à dire en bonne
collaboration comme l'a dit les
précédents en famille voilà pour parce
que c'est vrai que là je les bien notées
pour vous le conseil général des jeunes
c'est une instance où vraiment c'est
beaucoup on se sent comme dans une femme
merci